[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my good friend Dr
John deloney who's having a spectacular
week by the way congrats on your book
launch John very exciting building a
non-anxious life is now in the hands of
dare I say dozens
Millions different answers dozens and
dozens well if you're watching on
YouTube you'll notice I'm sporting a
deloney shirt that we just got in this
is not merch you can buy a bunch of
people put yeah they they printed up uh
my manager print up a whole bunch of
them John's mom decided to just make
some merch to make him feel better
that's right but it's fun so in honor of
Dr John delon's book launch I'm wearing
a deloney shirt I expect you to wear a
campel shirt during my book launch a
camel tattooed on my chest for sure
little aggressive but I like the spirit
behind it we're going to make it happen
man no thanks I'm excited to have it out
in the world man well hey we are taking
your calls today about money
relationships anxiety how it's all
interconnected so give us a call
8825 5225 is the number to call and
Adrien kicks us off in Miami Florida
Adrian welcome to Miami what's up how's
it going hey hey guys how are you guys
doing today pretty well how how are you
doing how can we help
better than I
deserve um so I my wife and I are um in
baby step number two right now um we
have about
$6,600 uh left in credit card debts but
uh we should be paying that off in the
next couple of months here um and uh
another portion of our debt is a car
lease um that we got into three years
ago and U that car lease will be up in
June of next year um and and I we just
want to know um should we try to get out
of that lease um as soon as possible or
uh wait the the eight months and um turn
in the car and then save up in these
next eight months to buy a car
cash that's a common conundrum when you
figure out dude we got fleeced on this
thing how do we get out there's a few
ways out of this thing the most common
one is to find out the early bu out
amount do you know what that number
is um yeah so I would have to come up
with
um about
$4,000 um because uh the the value of
the car right now doesn't match what
it's it's worth it's depreciated further
than what you owe on it yes welcome to I
cars are the stupidest things we
buy okay so you're four grand underwater
on this how much money do you guys have
in the
bank um well right now um to cover our
bases I mean we have our $1,000 uh
emergency fund okay and then everything
else are kind of throwing uh towards our
debt and what could you sell this car
for um right now blue Kelly Blue Book is
uh showing um
32,000 okay that's not bad so if you own
this thing you could go sell it for
32k and based on what you owe on it
would that give you enough to buy a
car um something cheap and
used yeah so if if we sell for 32 um we
would still need to pay um the lease
company on an additional $4,000 which is
um I guess the remainder of those uh uh
payments that we owe them for using the
car okay so how quickly could you save
up four
grand um uh
if we could probably save up four grand
in about four months four or five months
okay but that would leave us with
nothing left to purchase a car cash so
we would kind of be you know in the that
get you to Net
Zero yes so I'm gonna ask a Adrian I'm
gonna ask George a question on your
behalf is that cool yeah that's fine so
George he owes $32,000 on this deal and
there is a walkway Point coming up but
he owes 32,000 on this thing if he owned
the car and was trying to get out of the
debt we would tell him hey go over to a
credit union take out this the $44,000
loan and you just drop your total debt
32 to four essentially and so go go to a
Credit Unit take out a $7,000 loan buy a
$3,000 car get out of this thing and be
done does that does that apply for a
lease whatever would get you out of this
pickle of O if you owe the four grand
you can get a personal loan for that
much from the credit union it would get
you out of this a lot faster than four
months Adrian I'm wondering if you don't
go get a $7,000 loan at a credit union
get rid of this car buy a $3,000 car you
and I both know it's going to be a
dramatic shift in how you roll down the
street right you're going to have to
tint those windows so people can't see
you um but um you are instantly going
from owing $34,000 to 7,000 bucks you
cut your
debt significantly by doing
that what's your lease
payment uh right now it's uh 520 ouch
for how much
longer um eight months and the thing is
it's it's my wife's car and we just have
had a baby so she doesn't feel too
comfortable getting into a $3,000 car
don't care at all don't care at all
don't care at all don't you're talking
to the wrong two guys about that because
we both have kids
and it just doesn't matter like it
Comfort at this point is she rather
y'all y'all walk into a house every day
that's electric because y'all can't
breathe
right what do you drive yeah what do you
drive uh yeah I drive a 2013 Kia that's
paid off and it has $ 200,000 200,000
miles on it okay you're already rolling
with that $3,000 car cool could she
drive that and you drive the beater I
mean that's that's pretty beater George
well for three grand you're not getting
much you'll be lucky to get a 203 Kia
with 200,000 M on it for three grand in
this economy so I'd start your research
and see your options
but I don't know that I'd stick this out
until June of 2024 keep making these
payments that sounds miserable I want to
get out fast and $3,000 may be that may
be me being
obnoxious but honestly man this like
well she doesn't feel comfortable that's
what got y'all in this
mess yeah and I put the kid my kids in a
in a 1993 F-150 that didn't work too
great and everybody did fine I put my
kids in the back of a Corolla that was
golly I just wanted it to die and it
would never die cuz Corollas never
die but they did fine was it comfortable
no did I have to get all weird angles to
get the car seat out yes did I have
anybody any money on that car absolutely
not so Adrian you got to make a choice
of what sacrifices you guys are willing
to make and I'm not saying put your
children in danger but you also have to
not have the spectrum of either we're
going to kill our children driving a
beater car or going to stay in debt
forever there's more options than that
and so I think you need to talk to your
wife and you both have to agree on
here's the game plan here's what we
decided on it's for a temporary time
we're going to be out of this soon we're
going to upgrade the car and probably
within a year
right yeah yeah take um uh yeah you know
we make a a pretty decent income um so
uh about 140 you make 140 I think you
can scrape together four grand Adrian in
less than four months I'm thinking one
month a no do a no spend month we
covered only the basic bills minimum
payments the rest goes towards getting
out of this deep deep car hole we've got
ourselves no eating out no buying any
clothes nothing nothing nothing no Miami
lifestyle that you've been leading yeah
we'll get back to it soon enough my
friend thanks for the call this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Cel joined by my friend Dr John
deloney and we are here for you America
taking your calls atle
8825 5225 if you've got that burning
question a conundrum a Crossroads you
need some validation confirmation we are
here for youle 8825 5225 Sierra joins us
up next in Cincinnati Sierra welcome to
the show
hey George and John how are you guys
doing well how are you I'm doing good
I'm doing good um so I have a little bit
of an interesting situation and I'm sure
there are other people out in the world
that are in this in a similar boat but I
am looking for advice on my situation um
so two years ago my father passed away
and um I bought his house um or I I did
a cash out refinance and put it in my
name in order for it to be um to prevent
it from being foreclosed on um I don't
live in the house currently I haven't
for years but my sister at the time when
my father passed away lived with him he
was supporting her um and her kids until
the the kids got into um school age and
then they made an agreement to where
once once they go to school she would
start working and helping like help to
pay the bills okay well neither of us
expected him to pass away so now we're
in the situation where she had no job
and you know the house was being
foreclosed on fast forward to now I now
own the house 100% in my name and she is
working now however her her income is so
low to the point where she couldn't she
cannot afford the mortgage payment by
herself so currently am paying the
majority of the mortgage um she is
paying me what she can to get by because
she's also taking care of kids um but
I'm married I just got married and I
bought the house right before um we got
married and so now it's me and my
husband and I'm trying my best to figure
out a plan a plan for the future to
figure out how this can continue but not
be such a a big burden financial burden
on us because we are trying our best to
get our debts paid we're we're following
the budget we're on baby step too pretty
much um and you guys are renting right
now we are renting right now in a
different city but you have a mortgage
on this home that you own in a different
city your sister's still there with the
kids and you're losing money every month
just trying to cover the mortgage for
her yeah it feels like we're losing
money because every
um every extra dollar that could go to
our debt is going to this mortgage well
you're not in a place to be charitable
in this way and let your sister live
there for
free yeah she's not she's she we've I
got a renters agreement um written up by
a lawyer um she's signed it she's paying
me x amount of dollars um so what would
Market rent be for this
place um if she moved out you get a rent
her what do they pay for
rent I would suspect and I'm not too
familiar with housing market but I would
suspect I could at least get 1,500 a
month for it and what's the
mortgage the mortgage um I did a Cash
out refinance so I owe 119 on it but it
uh it appraised for 155 but since then
I've put about $20,000 in renovations so
what's the monthly mortgage payment
969 okay and what's she able to pay
every month she pays me $400 a month
let me ask a hard hard seemingly
insensitive question
okay um
okay how long has she been in this
financial
predicament um she it's been a couple
well back when my dad and her made an
agreement that she she was working and
then but she was having a hard time
finding child care she's a single mom of
two um so he told her that he would help
support her um while until the kids were
in school age right um so then she had
quit her job of five years um and really
was kind of depending on him um until he
passed away right and so you're doing a
noble thing you're trying to keep going
the agreement that he made with
her yeah but what we have here is your
dad trying to help you trying to help
mhm and we have somebody on the other
end of this help not realizing the full
sense of their
predicament yeah and she's had a couple
of years is that easy no I've sat with
with with moms who lost everything like
it's devastating and yeah it's her
responsibility to either come up with
the ability to pay for
$120,000 house which in this market in
this planet is unheard of right now I
won't say this planet in the United
States it is um to figure out a way to
cover that or to figure out something
else but yeah I and I I know that sounds
heartless and I'm might I don't want to
I don't want to beat up on single moms
or anything like that right but here's
what you're doing you're slowly
inching Inch by Inch by
Inch to exhaling really deeply every
time that phone rings and it's her on it
m and you go or every time she says Hey
the air conditioner is not working you
go what that is is slowly inching
towards resenting your sister resenting
the fact that your dad made this deal
and she doesn't deserve that your dad's
memory doesn't deserve that and it's
going to come down to not your help but
because you wouldn't draw boundaries and
say Hey you have to be the chief bread
winner for you and your kids mhm and
that's your boundary to
draw absolutely and I agree with you me
and her we've had our differences and
we've had really hard tough
conversations because I have set
boundaries and I've kind of you know I
used to pay her Wi-Fi and I used PID
this and that and now it's just like I'm
only going to help you with the
Necessities you know and until only
until you can get to a point where you
can cover all of this but I'm fearful
with her job that she's never going to
be able to afford that mortgage that's
but that's a choice that she is making
not you she has CH chosen that job and
yeah if you don't give her a deadline
she'll never get there yeah I think
that's the next step is we have an exit
strategy because guess what if you
didn't own this house what would she be
doing she wouldn't be able to afford
rent anywhere or she would have gotten
another job and figured it out exactly
and we need to help her kindly to step
into that where we go all right how do
we get you a different job where you
could support paying rent Market rent in
your area and if you can't afford it we
might need to move we have to start
dealing with these adult decisions but I
think what we can't do is continue to
coddle her and enable her and just
support her at our own Financial
destitute I mean you guys have your own
goals struggling you're broke yeah say
this way you're broke you're not in a
position to help and that sounds cruel
and
mean yeah yeah it it's almost kind of
scary because you know mine and my
husband's like our household income is I
mean to the outside world is pretty good
but it almost feels like I we have no
money in our account because I've either
spent it all on remodeling the house or
it's going to I think we stop sinking
money into this house I would sell this
house and that might be the way to get
hey months we're selling This months
it's sold and I'll sell it to you if you
have a job that you can afford
it yeah a part of me one wants to do
that but another part of me just thinks
that like you know this house my we came
up from nothing you know my parents were
really poor I know but listen to me
listen to me listen to me listen to me
you're gonna you both still have
nothing I need you to hear me say that
y'all have these assets that neither of
y'all can afford the way you're you've
managed it right
now and I didn't come from a lot my dad
was a policeman and then he became a
minister and I saw what the public
thought of public
servants and so I promised I would never
do that I was going to go make a bunch
of money and you know what I did cuz I
didn't Li I didn't change the way I
lived I didn't change my money
principles I ended up in way more debt
than my dad could have ever been in I
ended up broker than he did it's not
about we come from nothing and pulled
ourselves up yall got to make some hard
decisions about your financial situation
I think you have to draw some boundaries
with her and can strongly consider
selling this house and I know it's got
memories but right now those memories
are dragging both of y'all
[Music]
underwater hey if you're in over your
head with student loans and tired of
getting calls from collection agencies
if private student loan debt is taking
away your financial piece and you don't
see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with Y refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
open phones at
aa825 5225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life your money your relationships
your mental health all of it right here
in front of you on the Ramy show today's
question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
now you can find expert local help
schedule appointments and get special
offers exclusively in the neighborly app
so go download the neighborly app now to
start getting home repairs maintenance
or improvements done all right today's
question comes from Jason and South
Carolina and it actually came in last
week um before there was a Kick the Can
on the road um moment in the government
um but it said with the impending
government shutdown how do I as a
government employee combat the stress
and anxiety of possibly not getting paid
but still being required to show up for
work is that how that works yeah well
there's back pay so once they're back
they get the money but while you're
there it's not
happening which means they're missing
some
paychecks I've got my own thoughts on
that I'm the Sole Provider my third
daughter will be here in November we
have no savings and are in some debt all
right so I'm G to answer this George
globally because it's super frustrating
for
me if I had let's say um we had I want
to put something into context for
everybody okay so when covid happened
and we were told you cannot go into the
office Dave and the operating board
called that emergency meeting if you
remember that and Dave said we have this
much money in the account this is how
much cash this company has on hand and
we are a cash only company this is how
much we got this is how much cash it
takes to operate and so you can see it's
going to get real tight real fast here
is how things will go number one if it
get super tight I will not take a check
me the CEO and owner of this place
number two the operating board will not
take a check number three we will go
into the next run of Vice Presidents
will not take a check number four we may
have to look into like so he laid out
the map but in so doing he announced to
the whole company a transparently here's
what we got this is on everybody on the
same page here but I go first I'm the
leader I go first when times are good I
win big when times are bad I go first
number two the next round of leadership
go goes second the next run of
leadership goes third and to leaders if
y'all don't want to be a part of that
bye Felicia there's the door right but
here's how we're going to do this so ju
supposed that with a group of
senators who are sitting I just have
this picture George of them in a kitty
pool that they got at Walmart for $5 and
it's full of like bubbles and they're
throwing like Balloons with no no water
in them just like balloons at each other
it's a great mental picture thank you
for
that if it shuts down they still get
paid who doesn't get paid are these
employees who have kids trying to make
it so they're using these government
workers who keep this thing going for
all of us as fodder for their little
temper tanty games that they're trying
to play for an election coming up in in
a year and it's so
disgusting how they use people like
Jason as f for their little their little
future reelection campaign just pawns
this right awful game of chess and so
Jason if I worked for a guy if I had
gone to that meeting and Dave had said
listen here I'm getting mine if we shut
down if this shutdown actually happens
I'm getting paid my exx are getting paid
the rest of y'all we're going to cut the
low the the if the first in first out
whoever the last 100 employees are y'all
are fired after that I'm going to start
taking 20% from everybody's paychecks
right which happens across the country I
literally would go to my wife and say
we're out of here I don't trust that
person as a leader as a person of
Integrity as a stable operating leader
for the place that I that pays my
family's rent right and Jason a I want
to challenge you to begin to broaden
your Horizon and look bigger than this
particular job because you work for
people who will use you for their own
political gain and it cost them
literally nothing because they will
still get
paid the Senators doing this crap
playing tag with each other and then
here's what's gonna happen George gonna
play tag they're goingon to play tag
they're gonna play tag and then
something's going to set off and I hate
it but Jason out explore something
bigger and then that so that's that's
the big 30,000 foot view the reality is
the anxiety and stress is the alarm
system going off we may not have enough
money next month because our bosses are
acting like children and they won't
actually sit down and solve problems
they just want sound bites for their
Twitter account okay I'm going to always
go towards the alarm directly into it
what does this
mean George tell me if I'm crazy this
might mean I got to go to work until I
find some other job that will pay me
when I go every day instead of one
that's going to give me back pay if they
ever reopen and then you're going to
have to deliver pizzas at night to pay
the rent and you're GNA have to get up
in the morning and drive Uber on your
way to your job that you're not getting
paid for and then you're going to have
to deliver pizza you're going have to
figure out a way to get money and there
I wish there was another option to that
you can go borrow money and then you're
going to you're going to trap yourself
in a continued cycle of debt and false
security and whatever you're just going
to have to figure out a way to work on
Saturdays and Sundays and it's going to
suck but that's the real that's the
reality you face right yeah and what
this is he's in baby step two he's got a
baby on the way in November a third
daughter and there's this impending
shutdown so we call this storm or stor
mode and it's the only time to pause
baby step to P off debt and just stack
cash just keep your minimum payments
everything else stack as much cash as
possible until you're out of the storm
until mom and baby are home until we
know what the heck is happening with
this government and so that might be 45
days that sounds like about right if you
wait just month and a half get a side
job keep working stack all those uh into
savings then once the dust settles we
can move forward with the debt payoff
that's what I would do that would help
me with my anxiety and stress is some of
the reality pieces of it so and so let's
let's let's say out loud what our
fearless leaders are asking their
government employees to do because
they've only duct tape this thing
together for 45 days Jason I hate to
tell you this but I think today after
work you should stop by a local pizza
delivery place or get online and get
signed up for what's some food delivery
service Uber eat door Dash inart Amazon
Flex go through that as quickly as
possible or possibly call Walmart and go
visit a Walmart in your suit and tie and
go in there and say hey can I sling
boxes from 400 p.m. until 11:00 p.m. and
for the next 45 days I want you to stack
cash and want you look at your wife
who's expecting third baby and say hey
we can't go out to eat because the
people running our country are so um
uninterested in solving some of these
problems they're more interested in
throwing crayons at each other um but we
got a my job as as a responsible adult
is to make sure we have food and shelter
so let's go ahead and do that and George
just infuriates me because we watch the
news we watch these sound bites we see
these big things like oh my gosh this
and this and this side said that and
that side that said that and Jason who's
got a third baby on the way is the guy
who's at home and his wife who's on the
other end of this other end of this
pingpong match between children who
can't figure it out it just it's so
infuriating with me man it just it's
disgusting at every single level on both
sides of the aisle everybody involved in
this thing just solve these problems and
let's figure something out like adults
and move on 100% well you through this
in your book building a non-anxious life
six daily choices this is George keeping
me from getting I'm I wish Jason we had
your info we'd send you a book reach out
to us we'll send you a copy of John's
new book but go there's there are a lot
of things you can do other than vent on
Twitter or X or whatever it is and John
will show you how to recognize and break
free from a life spinning out of control
from chronic stress burnout anxiety and
there's a thousand reasons to feel all
those things right now but there's six
choices you can make every day to combat
that and John unpacks that in his new
new book building a non-anxious life you
can grab a copy today it's out in stores
online in the world and we love to see
it can't wait to see what kind of life
change happens from this book John go
get your copy ramsy solutions.com we'll
be right back with more of the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything cost too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds. for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
this is the Ramy show if you're a new
listener and you want to dive deeper
into some of the lingo we use on the
show The Baby Steps All That Jazz you
can go to Ramsey solutions.com and click
on the get started button and we've got
a great little tool to help you figure
out the next best step for your
financial Journey based on where you're
at today that's ramsy solutions.com and
click on get started Mary joins us up
next in Knoxville Mary welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi it's so crazy to be talking to
you how are you it's crazy to be talking
to Mary and Knoxville was just thinking
the same thing how are you that's crazy
made it I'm good I
know what's your question today uh my
question I have a $5,000 bonus for work
can com up in January um I think that we
I should put it towards my retirement um
but my husband thinks that we're already
putting too much into retirement and
that we should save it towards our house
fund
o I think option three George just had a
baby and they are strapped for cash
we'll do a GoFundMe
yes okay so this is exciting so you've
got a Bonus coming in January and you do
you feel like you're overfunding
retirement I don't feel like we can
overfund retirement because we're young
and so we can calm down when we're older
and so I feel like we can just go hard
when we're young you know okay so you
guys have no debt you have an emergency
fund and you're investing 15%
already um we're investing 22% whoa but
you still have a
mortgage no no no no to I'm sorry for a
down payment oh so you don't you're
renting yeah okay you're renting but
you're also investing 22% but you're
also trying to save for down payment
that sounds like a lot of things at once
to feel any
progress well it I mean we're have a
decent amount of progress I mean we have
like 150,000 save for a down payment wow
so what's stopping you from putting that
money down and buying a
house well we got married two months ago
so there it is it's just like this is
all figuring things out how old are you
to
yeah I'm 24 and 25 wow that's incredible
okay so here's the deal you guys are in
baby step 3B sl4 that's kind of down
payment investing and if you're
following the baby steps you would be
investing 15% and you could be saving
for the down payment now some people
like to hunker down and invest nothing
to save up even more for the down
payment faster you guys already have a
giant stash I would continue investing
15% let's dial that back down which
would give you 7% of your income back to
throw at a down payment
correct M so what if we kept doing that
when is your lease up with this uh
rental
situation uh July okay so what if we
started house hunting early this you
know spring summer and we added the
5,000 to you said the bonus is coming in
January so you'll have 5,000 there yeah
add that to the savings and then we put
a giant down payment down on this house
because the goal would be let's pay off
the house before we crank up investing
because to your point you guys have
another 35 working years to continue
investing you're going to be multi
multi-millionaires so the real question
is why is your husband fearful of not
having enough because if youve has he
crunched the calculators on this I'm
guessing he has what do you an
investment
calculator take what you have in
retirement now take what you're
investing every month calculate hey by
60 years old we're probably going to
have north of $67
million well I think well I think I'm
the one for one thing who's worried
about not having but also after we have
kids I plan on stop working being a stay
home mom and so just trying to set us
ourselves up best I think for that
situation okay well that would mean we
need to get his income up and our
expenses down to where we can make that
work because the retirement that won't
really be a factor you're not going to
be able to dip into that when you're you
know 38 years
old so I would be focused right now on
putting as much of a down payment down
to get your mortgage as low as possible
which would allow you to stay home
because that's a monthly expense until
it's paid
off yeah that makes total sense so uh I
I guess I'm on your team of let's put
this toward the down payment and let's
get this uh house sooner rather than
later okay I mean you guys are ready you
have an awesome down payment so proud of
you guys congrats on uh getting married
very exciting times you know what I know
you're off the line now Mary but I'm
going to send you one year Financial
Peace University and a year the premium
version of every dollar to get you guys
started I think that will align you and
get you on the same page which will be
fun can they at least go to dinner I
think dinner would be helpful to talk
about this everything's better over good
food so take that $5,000 and go to a
really nice like bonusy dinner and talk
about yeah like that I'm excited for you
congrats all right let's get to denell
in Sacramento denell welcome to the
show Hi how are you guys doing great how
are you I'm doing very well thank you um
so my question today um we are on baby
step two working toward paying off our
debt and um we we're able to free up um
about $55,000 to put towards some debt
but of course as it goes um now we have
a water heater out that we're going to
have to pay for OU so I haven't yeah I
haven't used that money towards the debt
yet um it happened within the same day
or so that we were able to get it and um
our house we do have home warranty I'm
not quite sure what that's going to pay
for yet um and then we also um had a
quote for about $5,000 which is about
the money we had so I don't know if this
is a silly question or not but um should
I put that money towards the debt and
wait and to see how much the water hey
is going to cost we do have the, saved
in our emergency fund um and hope that
the home warranty covers it or wait to
pay off that debt until we find out how
much it's going to cost well this time
frame is are we talking a week or two to
find
out uh the plumber that came out said it
could take six to 10 days the home
warranty people tend to be slow so um
even now we have no hot water they don't
care about that gosh it's awful yeah so
we're um we're just waiting around uh we
are reaching out to the I would be
calling them so often that they are like
okay here's your
answer yeah um and I take cold shower so
I'd be fine loves it his family hates
him but he loves it yeah of course this
happens when the weather starts cooling
down I would have been fine with it
summer but uh sure well I would I would
hang tight I mean if we're talking six
business days what I don't want you to
do is you throw the five granded debt
and now we know this storm is upon us
and then we have to go into debt to
cover this hot water heater that would
be a bad plan so if we're talking
waiting a week to see how this shakes
down to see if the warranty is going to
cover it which I hope it does I would
fight them tooth and nail cuz you know
their job is to make sure they don't pay
for it and so I would be looking at that
fine print fighting them and getting
this thing covered because that is time
well spent if it means $5,000 for an
hour of your
time yeah I guess I'm just I'm curious
because if I if we didn't happen to have
this chunk of money that we are blessed
to have right at this moment we would
have only had that $1,000 to throw out
this and I don't know what we would have
done otherwise oh that's true and a lot
of people have that hangup with baby
step one with a th000 bucks they go hey
what if there's an emergency over a
th000 well there's a thing you do where
you pause the baby steps we're going to
stack up cash as fast as possible we're
going to sell stuff we're going to get
the side job whatever we have to do to
come up with that amount of money and
those future paychecks are going to be
enough to cover it and that's what
happens uh often but what you also you
also have to understand the the plumber
the plumber is only used to dealing with
people with credit cards and so he's
going to look at you and say this is a
terrible decision to F to fix this to
repair this it doesn't have much time
left let's just replace
it and you have to change your mindset
to we don't have any other money so I
want to fix it well I can try to fix it
but it's going to be great because
that's all I have right now is
$1,000 and so often it's like well I got
to replace it because the plumber said
well I'm going to find me a plumber that
will come fix this thing whether they
duct tape it together as long as my
house is safe
until I can like Georgia said I'm going
to scratch and Claw and sell and do
whatever I have to do deliver pizzas and
I'm going to hate every second of it but
I'm doing it for hot water right and
then at the end of the month I'm going
to figure figure this thing out or the
end of two months or whatever it's going
take so be sure to shop around negotiate
tell them hey do you have a cash
discount hey I'll leave you a great
review in the neighborhood Facebook
group if you can bring the price down
and if you work that kind of magic and
you're not too desperate which I know
it's hard not to be in times like this
then uh we'll get through this but I'm
glad if they know how to install one
right um I could put some we could put a
message up here and somebody in this
building knows how to do it right 100%
figure it out yeah we're wishing you the
best andell thank you so much for the
call and uh best of luck with that debt
payoff and the water heater that puts
this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books I'm George camel he's Dr John
deloney we'll be back before you know
[Music]
it hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the Ramy
way just go to ramsy solutions.com today
to sign up for the newsletter again
that's ramsy solutions.com to sign up
for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by Dr John deloney this hour this is
your show America so call in at
aa825
5225 and I'm in an incredibly good mood
today because I'm wearing my deloney
shirt in honor of Dr John delon's book
launch week month if year it feels like
you're one of those girls who's like
it's my birthday month and I'm like
that's not a thing you get one day it's
my book day but this entire last month
has felt like I feel like your book
coming out I've heard more about your
book Drama than mine drama yes I didn't
know about the drama do you like this
color what's the right color what do you
think about the backside what about this
I I don't know about the like the amount
of decisions that go into making a book
it's unbelievable so and the amount of
second guessing you put on decisions
that you've already made is is pretty
amazing but now you know what it's like
to walk through the world feel like
delone feels good doesn't it well I feel
insecure you feel insecure I don't know
if it's the shirt I feel exposed and
both powerful and insecure I think I
think the exposure part is um that's a
big piece's really a short sleeve kind
of guy but but I think you uh both I
don't have the muscle mass both insecure
and uh feel powerful now you know how I
feel that's the deloney way well hey we
are here for you America and Eric is
here in Witchita on the line Eric what's
going
on hey how's it going going guys doing
well how are you good good I have a
quick question so uh my wife and I my
beautiful wife and I have been
uh it's a great caveat hey here's what I
guarantee he's about to do he's about to
say he thinks something and she thinks
different am I right and you think she's
wrong absolutely yes yes you're right
and I think she's listening so I'm I'm
so guys say my beautiful wife and women
say my amazing husband when they're
about to say and I think they're an
idiot the other person's an idiot so go
ahead tell us how your beautiful wife
may be an idiot
Eric all right you said it not me but uh
smart man we had um we've been doing the
steps and we are now down to just my
student loans which is about $9,000 left
um and she has an opinion that we should
not pay the student loans and we should
just start saving that do the three to
six months of of expenses because there
is um a very high chance that her car is
going to go out within the next year or
so uh and we don't we just have a, of
emergencies so I don't know um what you
guys think about that should we just
tackle the how much money do you have in
the
bank uh probably about we have about
3,500 bucks okay so you got a little
more than that baby step one emergency
fund and what's your
income uh 150 a year oh my gosh so these
student loans are paid off within a few
months Max the the student loans we if
we really buckle down we could we could
do it
within three to four months I think
three months so 90 days from now the
student loans are gone you said her car
could die within a year El
could we're going to have a presid
presidential election you know what that
means it's all going down Russia could
invade and after that a meteorite could
come and after that yeah can her car not
also be
repaired I mean it's it's pretty old
this is 2006 um and she I mean she'll
drive it until it doesn't go anymore
that's the type of woman she is but uh I
think we use if she's that scared she
should use that fire to fuel the
debt-free journey to go we got to get
out of debt fast we get the emergency
fund fast then we got to start the car
save fun fast because I know this
thing's going to be dead in a
year versus leap progging you said hey
we're doing these steps well the steps
are in order for a reason they work and
if you try to do multiple at once it
doesn't work it let's be honest though I
get how how much debt have y'all paid
off uh we we owned a business uh so it
was it's been
about it was about
35,000 uh but I sold my business as as
well so that actually helped us a lot
okay I sold I sold my business and then
uh uh paid everything else off how long
have y'all been chipping away at
this uh
about well um really about three years
okay because our business was kind of
going downhill and so I I remember I
remember like year two year three Mark
we've been hammering away and hammering
away and hammering away at this and felt
like
I should get my new car
now and then my wife and I were just at
Zero right we just we did all that work
to just get to zero and now you're
telling me I got to go two more years
and save up to buy the car that I want
which is a used car by the way so I get
her looking down the barrel of are you
serious right now like we have nine
we're going to go crazy and get this
thing done in 90 days and then we start
the savings thing all over again from my
car is this just our life and so I think
there's some truth to just sitting and
going yeah that does stink man we worked
really hard for three and a half years
we've grind and we scratched and clawed
and we paid everything off and now we
got to scratch and Claw again to save up
to buy you new
car right that is hard and that's
reality Eric what is y'all's take-home
pay is it about nine
grand uh it's nine grand yeah she yeah I
make uh 60,000 and she makes and we're
not investing right now for paying off
debt
right right okay so making 9 Grand a
month can you find 4,500 bucks can you
take half of that and throw it at the
debt and be done in two
months if you buckle
down we could I would have to look at it
again but but think about that then in
two months you free up 4,500 bucks you
were throwing at it plus that student
loan payment that means 9 months from
then you'd have 40 Grand Grand saved
you'd have your emergency fund plus
enough to get an upgrade for the
car right so that I mean we're talking
less than 12 months from now and so if
you start to paint that picture and go
hey honey I hear you I'm not trying to
be combative here I'm just saying look
at these numbers we can do this and do
it quickly if we buckle down do you have
something you could put on the
table I'm not going to go out to eat for
lunch with my workmates for a month I'm
gonna make
lunch yeah I mean I could I could do
that I'm just wondering if there's
something you could put on the table
that says hey I'm in I'm all in she
serious all all in I want these student
loans gone out of my life here George
and I say it's ludicrous to not pay
student loans and start saving up for a
car for another car that might die in a
year that's Madness you've got debt
staring you right in the face pay it
off get rid of that stuff um but man I I
think the conversation about okay here's
instead of presenting the all right
we're gonna we're just gonna go crazy
for 90 more days I love George's plan
like let's let's sit down and come up
with a 12-month plan here's how this
works if I buckle down I'm gonna make
this commitment because I know you're
going to need a car but I got to get
these student loans out of our house we
have to get these student loans out of
here let's make a plan and then in 12
months we're going to look up and we're
going to have emergency fund and you're
going to have a new car yeah or maybe
not a new car but a used new car A new
to you car right right it's that simple
and it's that hard Eric I wish it was a
shortcut yeah math and reality are no f
sometimes sometimes they're awesome but
we feel like funy duddies over here
being like you got to just pay but
that's how it works and it's worked for
so many people we believe in it that
much we're that confident in this plan
you got to do it in order with intensity
that's the only way it works thanks so
much for the call Eric this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive helped back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel co-host of course of this
show but also of smart money happy hour
with my friend Rachel Cruz and the
George camel YouTube channel which you
can check out on the tubes and of course
I'm joined by Dr John delone who's got a
fantastic show that he hosts right next
door to this studio called the Dr John
deloney show and you guys are crushing
it over there John you just passed
200,000 subscribers on YouTube I can't
catch up man you'll have me caught by
the end of the month so it's a losing
battle I see what you're doing there but
the team's done amazing George Campbell
show will pass my show and YouTube
subscribers soono well you just launched
this like mini documentary episode on
your YouTube channel that is amazing
yeah the the the we
actually they came to us and said hey we
want you to follow somebody for for 90
days and let's let's call your bluff
let's see if these little um steps to
build CH talk about let's see if this
actually works and so we put out a call
and we ended up with an incredible guy
who came forward and said I'm willing to
do film the whole thing and um and then
his wife ends up coming along halfway
through the the the the shoot but um
what the film team was able to do what
this guy was able to do he's just a
brave dude man um and they got to see
the behind the scenes me answering calls
saying I was wrong me going whoa this is
a big deal and this not a big deal kind
of some inside baseball on how the
coaching process works but um yeah it's
pretty incredible go to go to John
dooney.com on no I'm sorry go to YouTube
delone and you can check it out it's an
amazing um one episode series and um
it's about 28 minutes and it is well
worth your time the team did an incred J
show yeah they did a great job man
that's the start John next up Netflix is
calling you all right well John I've got
an article here that it made me happy
and a lot of people have sent this to me
and I shouldn't be as happy as I am but
there's those I Told You So moments that
I rarely get and this is one of you love
those here here it is from Business
Insider here's the headline 95% of the
nft market May now be worthless study
finds no to which I retorted they were
always worthless there was just people
stupid enough to pay for them you mean
um digital clip art is now suddenly not
worth billions John it has a scientific
name non-fungible token it's clip art
really fancy clip art fair point that
Bill Gates gave us originally for free
just for free wow through Microsoft
through Microsoft clippy here's some
pictures y'all can y'all can have and
here we are in 2023 still talking about
it uh here here's what it says are nfts
dead a recent study looking at the price
of thousands of collections seems to
suggest the answer is yes and so here's
the report out of 73,000 nft collections
the researchers looked at almost 70,000
of them and slightly over 95% had a
market cap of zero which is a fancy wave
saying it's
worthless so by their estimate almost 23
million people hold these worthless
assets this daunting reality should
serve as a sobering check on the
euphoria that has often surrounded the
nft space ouch and 79% of all nft
collections currently remain unsold the
surplus of Supply it's digital there's
not really a surplus of supply of a
digital they claim you know it's it's
John this is the one token but here's
what nfts really are it's like a
treasure map that points to the treasure
that you're buying you're buying a URL
link that goes to the photo you don't
even own the photo John the original
artist owns the photo you own the URL
that's a flex on your friends that says
I'm the sole owner of this one photo
that you can screenshot
instantly it's that insane like we
thought time shares were insane this is
like a sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership if you said hey um I
discovered a a a pipe that I can drill
down into the ground and get water so
all of us don't die I would say cool I
would like to I would like to buy into
that or if you said hey um I got another
drill and I drill down into a reservoir
of oil or I created clean energy it's
going to be free for everybody so things
that provide value to society say I'm
going to buy that if you said hey have I
got a deal for you for $4 million I'm
going to give you a picture of a link to
a digital
picture
that you can't really show anybody
because it's like not really the thing
but you just have to link to it i' be
like not even a piece of art like go buy
a Picasso I'm all about that hang out
art up in your I've got art in my house
I deeply value art support local artist
but I can't have it like in my house no
no no no it's it's not even that kind
it's it's an nft I would just have to
say like I don't know I don't know any
of the words you're saying and so for
that reason I'm out oh boy well you uh
you didn't miss out John fewer than 1%
have a price tag above six grand now
which is a far cry from the regular
million dooll deals of two years ago so
much hype and here's the thing the
people that were excited about it were
the people selling it which I told
people I said hey the people like get
into nfts if you're going to make them
and sell them good for you if you want
to hustle people out of a buck but also
but don't buy it thinking it's an
investment I'm going to resell it for
profit which is the only reason people
were buying them
anytime somebody drums up something and
like goes
a and there's not evidence you're not
like on this show you could say FPU it's
an n
no there's a Tracker there's 10 million
people right it's not just a guy on the
street corner going buy my thing it's
millions of people there's a debt free
screams almost every day like no no I
follow the plan and my family's free
anytime a group of people are like you
should do it too just be weary just be
weary because man dude well that's the
nail in the digital coffin John and you
can buy a link if you want to see a
picture of that digital coffin for the
low low price of $6,000 that was or or
the market cap of zero ouch so there you
go there's my segment of I told you so
thanks for that all right Ken joins us
up next in Orlando Ken welcome to the
show hey guys thanks for taking my call
sure um my my wife and I have been
listening for a long time following the
steps and uh we've been lately we've
been discussing baby step number six and
every now and then I'll hear in the
other room of the house we're debt free
so I knew I had to call you guys to
really discuss um my mortgage and paying
that down okay uh because because I'm
more about the investment side and she
really wants to get rid of the uh the
debt so just to just a brief background
we're both in our 50s I'm 54 she's 51
and I'm a physician she's an
occupational therapist and we have four
kids in their 18s and early 20s
essentially cool I have I bought a house
um after it was in 2021
uh is $1.5 million and I was able to put
just about a million down and I took out
a conventional loan at
525 525,000 at
2.5% 20-year term so there's 17 years
left and about
$120,000 worth of interest on the on the
number four side of things I've been
investing every month into mutual funds
which has grown nicely over the years
and I could
afford to take out approximately
350,000 to pay off a significant amount
of that uh what's left on the
mortgage um let's 17 years four what's
the balance yeah
474 th000 okay and you're saying you
have non-retirement investing happening
and like a brokerage
account yeah okay what's in there
mutually index funds about 450 to
500,000 whoa so you could pay off the
house
today well yeah I don't want to go down
to zero though but yeah I put a good
that's the question because your wife
wants to go down to zero and free up
that mortgage payment but you're what
you're seeing is but babe we could make
so much more leaving it in these mutual
funds the way the Market's going right
that's the argument yeah over the years
it's traditionally gotten seven to
eight% yeah that's a that's truly a hard
thing to Grapple with for the folks who
love to see those numbers go up and we
love investing around here but are you
already investing in
retirement yeah I have fully funded 401K
it's it's done very well amazing and
you're in your 50s what's your household
income uh gross uh 450 to 500 so riddle
me this could you not invest could you
not get back up to 500,000 in a
brokerage account within a few years Max
two years without a mortgage payment I
don't know about two years but well
without a well yeah no mortgage payment
could you put 200 out of 500 into that
brokerage
account yes there we go I yeah I would
double my investment monthly on a
monthly basis pretty quickly yeah you're
going to retire a multi
multi-millionaire Ken and in the
meantime I want you to have peace and
freedom and owe nobody anything and
allow yourself to enjoy these moments
with these kids before they're all out
of the house go on Amazing vacations
out baby pay that house off and
remember if you hate being debt free no
mortgage payment just go get yourself
into more debt you they'll always give
you a loan against that house Ken so uh
I I hope you become debt free I think
you're going to enjoy it I don't think
you'll look back man thanks so much for
the call this is the ramsy
[Music]
show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netw Suite was the software we use
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
too join the more than 34,000 customers
who trust netsuite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to learn more
get a free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
this hour give us a call at
aa825 5225 and if you're wondering why
I'm wearing a shirt that just says
deloney on it it's because I'm here to
support my friend John deloney during
his book launch week we're all very
excited about it around here uh and I'm
excited we have a launch party tomorrow
here at the uh Event Center it's going
off man can't wait I uh we've never done
one of these we haven't not with the
level of complexity slash level of um
work I still have to do in the next 24
hours to get this thing off we are
throwing a rager on the clock going be
pretty wild I'm excited about it well 12
bring your plugs it's GNA be loud yes
all right let's get to Carol in
Indianapolis Carol how's it
going good thank you how can we help
today uh my husband and I are debt free
net worth about a million we have six
months emergency savings
congratulations thank you thank you
after seeing multiple homes over the
last few years we bought a very thought
after lot so much so we're being
contacted by like private Builders
asking if we want to sell but we're
currently very happy in what we thought
would be a temporary home but we are
growing out of it my main question is is
now a good time to build since I owned a
lot do I need a realtor for custom build
um we have about 75 grand saved up for
what we think we're going to
build okay have you started reaching out
to builders because that's really the
only people you need to work with at
this
point oh yeah you think it's a good time
to build well the right time to build is
when you have the money and so that's
the beauty of of having that Financial
Freedom so if you're asking is the right
time to build is as far as the economy
goes rates or what cuz you guys are
going to take on a mortgage to do this
econom
we we would have to I mean our current
home is worth about
4805 that we have that's I don't know if
we should rent it make money out of
it no please don't please don't take
money out of it please please please
please please please don't take money
out of it don't put one house on the
Block for another house that's a way to
lose them both okay but we would still
need to take out a small mortgage maybe
200 Grand okay so if you if you sold the
house
yes so you sell the house you get you
know let's say 440 out of it MH and then
you have your 75 that puts you at a
little over 500 and you're saying hey
it's going to cost 700 all in we take
out a mortgage for 200 of
that it might be more closer to eight
now that I think about it okay it's just
so expensive well what's your household
income our household income it varies
from month to month but I could say on
average about 12,000 fantastic so let's
say hey we really need to keep this
mortgage around 3,000 and if we're going
to do that on a 15-year we can start
crunching the numbers to go are we ready
for this build are we ready to take on
an
$800,000 project or do we need to wait
and save up another 50 Grand 100 Grand
to make this make
sense right we could easily hold off in
this house for no more than two years
okay but it's not it's not too early to
do the homework and go hey let's contact
a builder let's start to see what this
would actually cost let's see how much
mortgage we could actually afford based
on our income and that will give you
some actual facts versus just I think
and maybe and I feel I like to have some
real numbers on it the fact okay and do
I need a realtor for a custom build no
you own the land you're G to have to I
would recommend getting several Builders
and having them give you a bid and have
some sort of idea of what you want the
house to look like and maybe you and
your husband can go through plans online
or hand them to a builder and say Here's
what we're interested in or look around
and ask people at your local church
whoever who have used a custom builder
we had a great experience we had a
terrible experience and then interview
them at your house they work for you
right and then ask give you Allin cost
and go through that whole process now
the spot where a realtor could come in
Carol is their expertise their
relationships with builders in the area
their negotiation skills uh project
oversight resale considerations things
like that I would still say hey there's
a lot of value in having a realtor
involved but do you need a realtor in
order to build a home if you on the lot
not
necessarily how do you say goodbye to
them since they helped us by B lot and
our current home ah so are they wanting
in on this because you already have a
current realtor that you
love yes she helped us by our current
home and the lot and she's mentioned
when you're ready to build contact me
contact me and I don't I haven't had the
guts to say goodbye well so maybe this
call her and ask her what does a realtor
help me do what's the value how are you
making money from this what is this
relationship look like and then if it's
if it doesn't make sense for you guys
just say hey thank you so much you've
been amazing but we're going to continue
forward without a realtor on this one
and maybe you do work with her and maybe
it's a huge blessing but I'm just if
you're the question is do I absolutely
need one
no okay I'm saving up to have some work
done at my place and it has never
occurred to me to call a realator maybe
that's on Me Maybe Maybe I'm Wrong on
that one but that's never occurred to me
um I have uh reached out to several
folks who would be either General
Contractors or Builders to come out and
help
me and if I did keep her I would pay her
out of my pocket correct it would you
pay a percentage of the total build yeah
yeah that's what I'm curious about what
how the deal would be structured if
she's willing to negotiate on that but
you're not buying a house she's not
finding you a house she's not searching
through MLS and she's not putting you
into a system um it's not a traditional
realtor relationship she yeah so maybe
you're going to pay her 05% or 1% to
help find you the right Builder and I
don't think she's going to be serving as
a general contractor making sure
everything that what the Builder's going
to do and so um I don't exactly know
what that relationship would be but if
you have a good relationship with her
she's been trustworthy sounds she like
she's been awesome sit down and say like
what would you bring to this equation
because otherwise I was going to call
start calling Builders and begin to
thumb through them that way love it best
of luck Carol that's a big project
excited for you guys all right Christian
joins us in Los Angeles Christian
welcome to the
show hey thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help hey so um I'm a I'm 27 I
live at home debt free um at my parents
house uh so I have no bills uh they
don't pay they don't charge me any rent
um I'm currently making gross 80,000 a
year awesome in savings I have 80 ,000
cash 130
liquid and I'm look I don't invest in
anything except for just my uh my
pension plan um so I'm not going to be
able to touch that anytime soon but um
I'm looking to invest essentially and I
looked at the market CDs and or if I
were to throw it at the stock market
into like a mutual fund um I do plan on
using my money to purchase a home within
the next two years um once I have enough
for for a down payment um which is
looking to be about it's gonna be about
150,000 for what I'm looking at okay in
my range so I'm looking at my money is
not doing anything for me right now
essentially it's like I said it's
880,000 sitting in the bank um I'm when
I say liquid I purchased a truck cash um
just because I never had a new vehicle
and honestly I'm considering just
selling it I'll get 50 50,000 for it
right now so yeah you said 130 liquid
that's including if you sold the truck
exactly I have 880,000 cash though and
so I'm looking to just invest and I'm
not I'm can't buy a home right now I I
mean the house the prices are just crazy
um they're not going to go down man I
hate to I know everyone says that
they're not um yeah I I understand that
I'm looking to I guess my long-term goal
is like my Five-Year Plan essentially is
I'm gonna just you know stay at home not
pretty much pay no bill just my minimal
regular bills but five years can I push
back on that
why um I know it makes economic sense I
get that but man you got to go out and
live your life you got to learn how to
pay bills you got to learn how to live
on your own have your friends yeah no I
I get that um I'm just I don't want to
yeah I can go out and get like a cheaper
uh condo I don't want to get wrapped up
in HOAs I guess I'm right now the home
prices that I'm looking at it's
like, you're you're a 27 28y Old
Man Grand a year living with his mom
yeah you're saying I should just go on
rent yes because listen you this is this
is a the math problem you're you're
right the math problem I am able to save
this much money at my mom and dad's
house yes there is the psychosocial
development side of this where you learn
how to be an adult how to be a grown man
and lean on yourself that discomfort of
having a place making the calls having
to set up your own electricity call it
when the Bill's wrong all of those
things are about being an adult going to
your neighbors and saying hey we all
turn the music down those are all skills
your body needs to learn that you don't
get when Mommy's doing your laundry for
you at 30 years of age so Christian sell
the truck too much of your world get
something reasonable don't invest this
money put it in a high yield savings
account because that time Horizon is way
too short my
[Music]
friend
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality George camel joined
by my colleague Dr John deloney strictly
colleagues sometimes friends best
friends and we are here for you America
the number to call
8825 5225 5 we love having a
conversation with you helping you take
the right next step with your money your
life your relationships all of it
Taylor's up next in Milwaukee Taylor
welcome to the
show hey how's it going guys great how
are you you're a little muff speak
directly in your phone for me a little
muffled is that better
perfect okay um so my fiance and I have
been struggling to pay off a little bit
of our credit card debt and I was
thinking the other night she works she
makes about 14 1450 a month take-home
and she's paying we're paying $1,200 a
month in daycare um and so I thought to
myself why we do do instacart um and and
door Dash and stuff on the side um and I
thought to myself why don't you just
quit your job put your two we notice in
she's starting Cosmetology School in the
spring anyway so she's going to have to
be leaving her job when you quit your
job um and just do instacart door Dash
uh stuff like that uh full time um with
our son staying at home more with him uh
and it's kind of funny I was listening
to you guys a show a couple days ago and
I kind of feel like a little desperate
right now um and I picked up something
that stuck with me and I said that when
you're feeling desperate you're gonna
make a you're gonna be stupid you're
gonna make a stupid Choice yes good call
man so I thought man you know maybe I
could get on here and talk to you guys
and see how you guys feel about this
what do you feel desperate about brother
just so we're current
so listen to the show we've been paying
off we've been throwing all of our extra
pennies um at our credit cards to we
have just over 20 about 20 $23,000 in
debt um and we want to take care of it
because we want to buy a house so we've
been throwing all of our extra pennies
at it well I had to pay for books um for
my school I'm uh apprentice electrician
ibw and books came do so I went to pay
for my books and I thought I was adding
my credit card payment but I paid the
whole thing so that was a couple weeks
ago and so the last couple weeks we've
been kind
of literally living paycheck to paycheck
working out of a negative bank account
trying to catch up because we totally
did not expect that because then a
couple days later her our payment for
daycare um glitched and it double paid
that week so we paid out like $1500
extra that we were not expecting that
week and so we're finally just that was
a couple weeks ago finally just tomorrow
you know when she gets paid uh we won't
be working out of a negative account we
can get back on track you know working
at her debt um she just got into a car
accident Friday so which it might help
it wasn't her it wasn't her fault
someone pulled out the front of her um
so in a roundabout way we might not have
to pay her car loan anymore you know and
we'll just buy a beater C because God I
don't want to pay I don't want uh
another car so the 23,000 total between
the car loan and the credit
cards no I'm not including that car loan
into this if we include that it's up
over 40 but I don't think we're gonna
have to I think yeah I think eliminated
my income right now is400 a month um
take-home um we I work a lot of overtime
with my job uh and it's temporarily
permanent over time I guess because with
being a a those hold on those are
opposite words with overtime you're
bringing up 2,400 a month no no no with
overtime it's like 3,300 a
month and it's that's consistent for I
know but that's 500 extra dollars right
I'm sorry 33900 extra dollars but I
wanted to use I I don't want to count on
that overtime because at any point it
could get eliminated right here okay
you've got you've got money chaos but
let me just cut right to it dude
underneath that you've got other chaos
what
is well so a couple years ago we wanted
to buy we really wanted to buy a house
so we thought we could move into my
parents house and save up some money uh
well that didn't work Co hit and this
hit and we got Frugal with the money and
it just it just underneath that what's
underneath
that um here's what you sound like to me
okay you sound like a dad you got one
kid or two kids two two
kids is this woman your
wife um no we're engaged we've we've
been engaged for about eight years
why we I don't know we just have so when
we hold
wait we don't have time to go through
the whole thing here's what it sounds
like yeah yeah yeah yeah you sound like
a guy who is fraying at the edges in a
way that makes me makes me nervous for
you the money is symptomatic IC of a
life of a guy playing whack-a-mole with
his
life yeah can I I'm going to ask you a
hard question you don't have to answer
it are you using right
now um I I drink no yes here's how I
know that the way you are living your
body was not designed to handle the
wack-a-mole stress you put on it and you
have to have something to shut that
system
down either you have something to speed
up that system to keep up with it or you
got to have something to shut it
down I'm a I'm a I'm a very anxious
person yes I am
yes what you need my man is to uh you
have to have a plan but you got to have
something beneath all this dude let me
ask you what are you running
from failure I guess yes why what are
you scared of man you have a woman who
loves you you got two healthy kids
yeah I mean honestly this might sound
kind of crazy but I've always been
commitment I'm afraid of commitment I've
always been really good at everything I
do but I can't ever just stick with one
thing
okay but when you get lasered in on
something I bet you're freaking amazing
aren't you I'm enjoying my career right
now yeah that's right I am but are you
the kind of guy that's going to get
certified and get a great job and six
months later you're going to be like oh
look over
here uh
um no okay I can't I can't so here's the
deal 33 I don't want to start over again
I love I love what I do I really do
that's amazing that's
amazing you are I need you I want you to
do something crazy when we get off this
call and it's going to sound insane okay
I want you to make a fist and I want you
to put it right in the middle of your
chest and I want you to walk into your
bathroom and shut the door and say these
words out loud I love this guy
and I want you to stare yourself in the
eyes and my I'd be willing to bet money
that that's going to be hard for you to
do because right now you have a woman
telling you I love you so much I'll I
will play your little commitment
gymnastics even though we're together
for eight years because she loves you
that much and you got two kids you love
you got parents who are like dude move
on in you have a boss that's like do we
want you so bad around here we're going
to give you extra time cuz we need you
and your skill set and your character
around here the only person I hear in
your life that doesn't believe in you is
you and that has to stop today you got
two little boys you got two little kids
looking up to you
man okay I just called an electrician
and spent an ungodly amount of money you
know what I looked at that guy and I
said I said I trust you to take care of
my family because you have a skill set I
don't have please help and he came in he
said I got you that's what you do for
guys like me yeah every day I do that
but you have to address the drinking and
you have to address the
anxiety and you have to address this
pretend I'm not getting married because
I don't like commitment but I'm with the
same person I've built a family in a
home but sort of with this woman marry
her and be done with that so your body
can
rest right and then we give you a plan
on the money we'll give you a plan on
the money man just got to follow the
plan
okay does that I mean does that sound
good it does yeah Taylor I don't think
the solution here is man if she just
stays home our problems are over you're
just trading one problem for another
Wacko and it's not going to get you out
of the money mess it's not going to be a
big dent in the financial hole you guys
have created but you got to get serious
about this if she can get her income up
that will help the problem we're going
to hook you up listen I'm going to send
you building the non anxious life my new
book I want you to follow it the second
thing is I'm going to send you every
dollar the best money app for yall two
to use together for a year for free I'm
going to send you the FPU lessons for
free but y'all got to do them as a
couple and make some commitments and I
want you to send me a wedding invitation
in the next 30 days game on my brother
I'll go with you John it'll be fun
Taylor thanks so much for the call hang
on the line Austin will pickup we'll get
you all those goodies man wishing you
guys the best that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the
[Music]
books
hey it's John delone co-host of the
ramsy show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsy show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to Ramy solutions.com
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel co-host
of smart money happy hour and of course
leading the charge on the George cam
YouTube channel joined by Dr John
deloney host of the Dr John deloney show
you catch all those shows on the Ramy
Network and uh and a lot of other places
as well we're pretty pretty much
everywhere these days all over
everywhere so give us a call at 8825
5225 if you want to jump into the
conversation if you've got that question
about money life relationships whatever
it may be we'll give you our best and
sometimes it's not great but it's what
you got free but it is free it won't
cost you nothing all right Nick starts
us off in Salt Lake City Nick welcome to
the
show hey um so yeah I I've had a pretty
big life change recently as far as
income goes about a year ago I was
making $2,000 a month working at a steel
plant and then my brother-in-law told me
that he thought I could sell and it
turns out I could and my income has now
since quintupled I don't know it would
take me five years to do what I I mean
it's it's an insane jump and my wife and
I are trying to manage it and I feel
like we're hemorrhaging and we haven't
saved enough considering how much we've
made congratulations congrats so what
are we talking are we talking 10K a
month
closer to 20 whoa congrats is that your
take-home pay my boss thinks uh for tax
I'm not sure what my that's the other
thing I got to figure out taxes in this
too and so I just oh they're not taking
taxes out nope nope I'm technically a
self-employed
1099 okay so you better be putting away
30% of that every single month in a
savings account I hav putting away so we
save so we have between our taxes and
then our church donation we put side
about 45% okay and then we live off of
about well our budget puts us at 10% but
I feel like we're not doing that is what
we're living off of and then we try to
save the other 45 but that's not what's
been happening how how long has this
been going
on about six months okay um cut yourself
a whole bunch of
slack okay yeah like this is this rare
air congratulations y'all had a fun run
and now you got to go be adults and it's
all good okay yeah don't live in the a
Shucks a because what you are
experiencing is the upside of sales what
you haven't experienced is when our
Congressman decide to throw tennis balls
at each other just for fun and shoot
each other with Nerf guns and shut
everything down the other side of sales
right you're like a farmer now yeah and
you farm no money no money no money then
crops and then no money right so that's
awesome you just got a plan for the
future so 6 months youall had a wild
time good times and now we got to be
grown-ups right yeah okay so give us a
picture of your financial situation do
you guys have any debt you have money in
savings so we have a little the only
debt we've brought on was on the advice
of our accountant to try and bring our
tax Li our tax liability down um we
bought my wife a new car um before that
she had a little car that we had paid
off and I have a truck that I have paid
off your accountant told you to go get a
car
loan he told us to get a loan so we
could not necessarily a loan but to buy
a car so we could use it as a ride off
oh my
gosh dude is Michael Scott your
accountant like how did you think this
was a good
idea that was it's what I've had a lot
of people around me that they said
that's what they did and so that's what
we kind of thought we should do you need
different grounding necessarily but yeah
okay what's the car
loan um it is 32,000 okay the good news
is you have an amazing income and you
can pay the this thing off really fast
and it's now not too big of a portion of
your world 60 days you were making two
grand a month I would be like sell this
car today 60
days yeah 6 Z got it okay 60 days you
have you have to make very focused goals
with your money right now you're in baby
step two you have a th000 bucks in the
bank I assume you have a lot more than
that in the bank right now 15 in the
bank 15 of the bank so this car loan can
already get cut in half today and then
with the next few paychecks the bank I
guess if you include I I won't talk
about the tax account but yeah 15 and
saving yeah tax account doesn't that's
that is Untouchable we don't touch it
don't touch it don't touch it it does
not exist yes until tax time and they go
hey you owe $60,000 in taxes and instead
of going oh my gosh you went okay yeah
we save for that great yeah so we're
going to pay off this car as soon as
possible then we're going to stack up
three to six months of expenses in an
emergency fund that we also don't touch
unless there's a true emergency yeah and
that's what that's what this money is
for because we live off of about
including the car about 2500 a month
because our rent is only $800 great so
this will help accelerate you to Baby
Steps 456 now are you in a home you said
you're renting you want to buy a home
one day we want to buy a home next year
right now the situation we're in we got
um we got fortunate I suppose um our my
wife's grandparents have a house that
they it's a 42 that they rent us and so
we're in a
800 bucks your Salt Lake
City no well we're close to Salt Lake
okay Nick you all are winning life right
now you falling through the a glitch in
The Matrix man this is your chance to
get a hit that's I yeah I mean it's just
I I mean I just learned I have a talent
in sales I mean I've broken every record
this company had and it just was it's a
lot to handle but also but six months
you can have a lot of talent or you
could have just gotten real
lucky yeah that too I don't know that's
the thing right both so it's probably a
little bit of both and so
um George tell me if I'm I'm crazy here
I almost sense a need for you guys you
and your
wife to roll back for maybe just say
we're going to do a 90day Sprint but
roll back some of the gazelle
intensity remember what it felt like to
be broke and get that laser
focused yeah because if you don't you're
gonna wake up in a
mess yeah you're gonna buy a house that
you can't afford you're buy a house
based on 20,000 bucks a month and then
the Builder's going to be like what are
you doing you're going to your income's
going to keep going up and you're going
to buy a house based off $30,000 a month
and someone's GNA tell you you got to
get a card to right off too and you're
gonna get a BMW and next thing you know
you're gonna be Dave Rams you be
broke yeah so here's the deal you got to
keep living like you make $2,000 a month
for the next six months months until
you're out of this hole you're in a
great place you have a financial
Foundation you're investing 15% you're
saving money towards that down payment
cuz you have like a fake life right now
paying 800 bucks a month in rent making
$20,000 a month utilize this while you
can instead of the YOLO Vibes that
you've been putting out and you will be
in such a great place financially six
months from now me and George tried to
convince people for three years the
government is not charging you any
interest on your student loans this is
there's never been a better time in
human history to pay them off than right
this second your payments are on sale
and 1% I have zero student debt I know
but I'm saying 1% of America took our
advice oh yeah the other 99 are right
now going oh God what are we gonna do
similar to you if you for six months
pretend that y'all are broke and you get
an enti an emergency fund you pay off
this a car get a new accountant go to
ramsy solutions.com tax get a new
accountant for God's sakes
um fire Michael scottt but you do this
for 6 months you owe nobody anything you
have six months emergency fund built up
and youall starting a house fund brother
your whole world is different and so is
your marriage everything's different
congratulations man never do it for the
write off that's just life advice for
you America this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
and if you haven't heard our first ever
money and marriage getaway is happening
October 19th through the 21st right here
in Nashville Tennessee just up the hill
from our headquarters at our brand new
Ramsey Event Center and I'm so stoked
about this event and I found out John
I'm going to be a part of it did you
know that I fought hard I made the
lineup to not have you on the lineup but
they're bringing you AB board well John
delone and Rachel Cruz have notoriously
headlined this event for years now but
this time it is a full weekend getaway
people are traveling from all over the
country to hang out and I you're going
to be talking about sex and intimacy
which I'm excited to don't misunderstand
John they will notc to hear your your
sessions or budgeting which is very
similar yeah both have been known to
cause great joy I'm pretty clear on the
minute by minute I saw recently that I'm
taking baby steps one two and three Jade
will be covering some budgeting and you
will be talking about I love the fact
that I said sex and intimacy and you
were blushing well I was trying to think
of a joke I could tell on air that was
familyfriendly we don't have yeah so it
was tough but I will can I tell you the
name of my talk I'll be giving yes spice
it up pillow talk the dirty secrets of
budgeting I was very proud of that one
and it involves pillows so that's one
reason one re those aren't
pillows excellent George we're going to
have so much fun this really is such a
blast and you and your spouse will be
equipped with tools to cast a vision for
your family set goals create a life you
both love and at the money marriage
getaway you will have the get this
undistracted time to disconnect from
everyday life and reconnect with your
spouse there's going to be interactive
sessions Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney
Jade warshaw myself we're going to be
your guides to discuss money
communication boundaries intimacy and
tickets cost $799 for this multi-day
event for couples so if you're out of
debt and you've got room in the budget
please please join us we're going to
have so much fun October 19th through
the 21st come make it a party in
Nashville Tennessee ramseys
solutions.com events we've still got
some tickets left that's the place to go
Ramy solutions.com events it's going to
be different than Ramy events in the
past for a couple different things one
is it's not just going to be us um doing
keynote after keynote after keynote very
different format there's a whole lot of
time
of access like here's what we do in our
house let's have Q&A let's talk a lot of
behind the scenes a lot of Q&A a lot of
activity time let's figure this stuff
out yeah so a lot of working this
through the goal is is that um when we
leave when all of us leave we have some
tools to go home and make our marriages
better and we have some time to practice
this with experts and other people while
we're there and there's going to be
other people practicing too so you're
not going to be by yourself and it's not
going to be me and Rachel and you and
Jade do what it's not going to be me and
you and Rachel and Jade what' you
say Jame I thought producer James was
talking trash James is doing the sex
talk that was my bad J James will be
talking about sex and intimacy okay but
it's not it you're going to come away
having spent considerable on of time
with us we're not talking at you we're
talking with you we're all working on
our marriages too so it's going to be
something that we're all going to do
together I'm pretty excited about it
stoked on this event and at that point I
will be the dad of a two-month-old so
maybe I'll do a talk on parenting I'll
be an expert by you are an expert you
are an expert show you how to change a
diaper like you've never seen before
this is going to be fun I bet your
diapering skills are A+ I try and I'm a
little OCD John A little I try to get
the Ruffles out I try to make the the
little flaps even it's all right we'll
get there let's get to the calls before
James takes us off the air Georgia is in
Chicago Georgia welcome to the ramsy
show thank you hello what's going
on um I bought a car the end of July and
I was lied to about the price of the car
um it was some from someone that I go to
church with and um I signed the
contract without looking at it because I
trusted this man and now I can't afford
this
car okay tell me more what do you mean
you were lied to about the cost so they
said it was a certain price and you paid
that price yes they told me on the phone
it was 25,000 okay um and I had gone to
take a trip two days after I bought it
to North Carolina there was some issues
with the car and out of frustration I
was looking at the paperwork I got from
the the sales and noticed that they had
charged me $7,000 more for the card than
what I was
told okay how I'm so confused as to how
you walked out of there having paid
$32,000 that wasn't a red flag to you
like it came out how did you pay for the
car
um I went to my credit union but like I
said it was from someone from my church
and I trusted him so after we had
discussed you know the cost and their
and all the taxes and everything and the
3,000 I was going to get out of my old
car I kind of figured it would take me
down to about 22,000 for the car so
after discussing all this with him and
signed a contract without reading it
because again I trusted this
man so it was out of the frustration
when I pulled the paper out of my glove
box um I noticed that it was 32,000 not
25,000 for the actual price of the car
or did they tack on fees
warranties what made it 32 actual price
what did he say when you called
it he told me that they had had two
other Ford Escapes on the
lot and
probably just got it mixed
up so what are they going to do to make
it right they ain't G to do
nothing I've contacted multiple I I bet
you I have called 30 lawyers and because
I signed that contract this has nothing
do with lawyers this has to do with have
you gone up to meet in person with
management not angry and not enraged but
say hey this salesman is a friend of
mine he told me this number he admitted
that they mixed it up he admitted that
they mixed up the cars I want the car
that I discuss with the salesman because
you all switch the cars on
me yes I did and they still refused to
do anything about it even if the
salesman would have told the the the
manager that he told me that they still
refused to do anything about it okay and
you've talked to attorneys and they say
sorry yes okay so if you have a a legal
professional telling you their ethical
duty is to not take your money because
you don't have a case that means you
don't have a cas
case and sometimes they'll tell you we
don't know that you have a case but we
think we can win this let's figure
something out and what they've all told
you is honey we're not going to take
your money it would be unethical for us
to take your money what does that
mean you found yourself in a quandry and
so I want you to do me a favor okay as
hard as this is going to be I want you
for a while to forget about that man
that you said you trusted because that
doesn't factor into the situation that
you found yourself in now okay did he do
you wrong yes did he lie yes did he not
protect you whatever but you said the
words I kind of figured and then I
signed a contract and that's that as you
as an adult have to say I also signed a
contract without looking at the final
numbers I did take his word but I didn't
do my due diligence also and here I sit
with this thing and now I got to figure
out what to do is that cool cuz what
here's what you're doing that anger and
that rage that you have however
Justified right it is he's off doing his
thing it's only poisoning you right yes
so let's do our best to set that down
however righteous and unjust it is you
got to deal with a car that you can't
afford So when you say you can't afford
it what does that
mean
um it's actually the price of the car
was 32,000 but by the time you I attach
a warranty on that I'm up to 38,000 now
what is the loan
amount um if I wait seven years $448,000
no not if you wait seven years what was
the loan amount you took
out uh 38 okay and what is your
income uh it's 31 uh 3100 a month okay
and what is the car worth
today um I'm going to guess around
25,000 okay here's the deal you bought
too much car anyways even if it was2
5,000 and so here's what you can do you
could probably get rid of that warranty
and they can refund you for that you can
leave Yelp reviews you can call the
local news and get him to a story but at
the end of the day you got to realize I
got to pay a stupid tax I played a giant
role in this conundrum and you might
have to sell it and eat the cost of that
and come up with the difference to get
rid of this loan and get a reasonable
car but you sure learned your lesson
you're always going to read the fine
print of every single thing you sign for
the rest of your life and I'm sorry that
you had to learn it a hard way we're
hoping for the best for you hoping this
can get resolved from this dealership
Georgia thanks for the call this is the
Ramsey
[Laughter]
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show hey if
you enjoy this show please consider
doing something that costs you very
little time or money and that is
consider subscribing to the show leaving
a review where you're listening and
sharing it with a friend it's one of the
best ways to share the show we have a
marketing budget of of close to zero
because you guys are the marketing
budget because you're naturally talking
about this sharing this hey you got to
check out this clip you got to listen to
this episode I listen to the Ramsey Show
and podcast wherever you're listening
tell people about it it helps a ton and
we so so appreciate we want to spread
this message to as many people as
possible in the next year all right
let's get back to the phones Sean joins
us in Durham up next Sean welcome to the
Ramsey show Howdy thanks for having me
sure what's going on um so my wife and I
had an impass on some financial
decisions and since we got ourselves
into clear using ramsy Solutions you
know 20 years ago we figured we' we'd
call y'all to try and try and help us
with this dispute all right I'm team
Sean George's team wife let's go we'll
defend both of your
honors so um we've got a daughter that's
finishing up high school um looking at
college career field that she's looking
at is probably a graduate School type
thing um and just looking at the schools
and looking at the cost of housing um
I'm looking at it and I'm thinking you
know what I'd rather just buy her a
place and you know build on an
investment and my wife's looking at that
decision and suggestion and going we
don't take out any more debt until our
home our own home is completely paid off
and you know looking at the baby steps
looking at all the advice to the years
we're just trying to figure out if we're
in the same place or if that's something
we should be be considering man John is
regretting choosing your team at this
point I am too dang it we were so close
man your wife's right Sean your wife's
right so you're seeing this on paper
right you're looking at on paper going
man we're going to spend a th000 bucks a
month for the next four years six years
might as well get some Roi out of this
is that the idea an RO Roi but also
possibly a place she could live in long
term um you know where going to an
investment in my kids um you we're
looking at uh North Carolina Wilmington
out on the coast okay so a few hours
from you guys how far is
that it's about two two and a half maybe
maybe three hours on a bad day which
most most days are bad days when people
want to go to the beach okay so let's
say HVAC goes out at this place are you
driving three hours to go fix
it no we're hiring someone to take care
of that okay so that's going to be
something to think about as aan on that
answer what kind of question was that
it's a possibility people don't want to
pay the property management fees and
what is the cost of rent out there let's
say she lived on campus or does she plan
on living on
campus um I mean I'm we're we're
weighing the cost right now my my fear
is what if she gets some Foo like man
I'd love to live on campus next year and
you're like no I bought you a place you
have to live there and now you're
renting to random college kids well and
almost every College I know of has a
freshman live on requirement is that
right um she won't technically be a
freshman because of the number of
credits she's pulling because she's
doing College while she's in high school
ah okay so so let's back let's back out
of this get to pick Let's back let's
back out of this and look another
Direction because I do dude I've lived
that life I know the ring board is
astronomical particularly the boarding
the colleges have make a significant
amount of money off the board plan with
their Mark Professor so I know too there
you go so you know how that game works
and so um um so let's do the well what
college do you work at oh you don't have
I work at North Carolina Central
University
okay we could talk offline about that so
sure what do you owe on your
house um we owe a 100 Grand we've gotten
it down to 100 how long would it take
yall to do a Sprint and get that sucker
paid
off um our best scenario we for about
three or for about five years we've been
chunking like about 20K into it every
summer off of my wife's seasonal income
so we we've been hitting it hard for a
while our best scenario is 3 to 5
years
okay um yeah just and and that's not
figuring into the scenario of you know
we plan on bankrolling her education
yeah that was the other question is is
this college completely paid for for
sure we we we're going to basically
shift into pounding down the house into
paying for college Okay so I'm going to
say something that's never a fun
conversation but it's unfortunately one
I've had to have probably 10,000 times
in the last 20 years that's I I we
overstated that but such it is um you're
a professor your child has said here's
what I want to do probably going to end
up in grad school that makes sense
that's the path her dad took it may even
be the path her mom took um both me and
my wife went to grad school for a long
time both of us have been professors all
that and you and I also both both know
that every year millions of people enter
in as freshmen with very clear
plans and millions of students every
year change plans meet somebody I met a
girl at a church camp just a few weeks
before school started and I turned down
a full ride to go somewhere else right
so it's all over the place what I would
hate for you to do if you told me hey
I've got cash I want to buy uh a condo
and whatever I would say buy it right
now
awesome but if you saying I'm still
trying to pay off my house we're going
to shift paying off the house into
helping cash flow college and so we're
going to have to take out a second
mortgage on a
place man that you're leveraging your
family at and I hate to say it like this
but you know I'm right at the whims of
an 18-year-old and that's a I would tell
you I wouldn't tell you to do that just
for you and your wife if youall wanted
to to have a Airbnb or whatever but even
more so man that makes me nervous that
from knowing how many college students
I've worked with over the years that
have great plans and then Mom gets sick
boyfriend moves my professor quits they
shut down the program any number of
things happen and suddenly you've got
you got a house payment to make and you
have a a child who's like well Dad I'm
just going to come back home and I'm
going to go to Central and all a sudden
you're like well what are we going to do
now you see what I'm
saying right I just wouldn't do it yep
yep and I know how hard that board plan
is to God Almighty how hard that board
plan is to pay for geez man that
hurts it it just it's just yeah I look
at all the hard work we've done and
looking at what would be half of what
would possibly go into our house is just
going out the window well I mean it's
it's providing here a place to eat and
it's a place to
sleep I mean it's not going out the
window but I see that you're not you
don't have what you project might be a
return on this down the
road
yeah seeing it they for a lot of it like
if if you're going to do right she'd be
required to live on campus correct thing
so yeah there's no option there's just
so many variables here and there's if
one thing goes wrong this whole plan
falls apart and at 7% interest on top of
your current mortgage it's going to add
more stress than it's going to be a
blessing and I'd rather see her go get a
part-time job while she's in school she
needs to help pay for some of this I
like that game and you know I I I think
kids are resilient sometimes an
understatement with my daughter I think
full time's good you're a great dad I I
don't think this kind of love you man I
wish Sean was my
dad Sean buy me an investment condo
please I like my dad but I do like your
like your heart man and I like just try
to think through all this that's
fantastic absolutely well John that
reminded me on this desk a team member
of ours got this a letter for his
daughter from discover the Discover at
student cash back card she's 18
debt-free this man lives by the Ramsey
principles and she's getting marketed
all this very bright pink
garbage and uh it's amazing John how
they Market to can I tell you when I saw
the envelope I thought you were going to
embarrass me with like a money marriage
Love Letter I'm not kidding I wish nope
here's here's the Love Letter John save
money while you build your credit
history enjoy 0% intro APR on purchases
for 6 months and then it says after that
your standard variable purchase APR
applies currently 18 to 27% you know how
many 18-year- olds know what that
is less than 0 they're not looking at
that all they see is 5% cash back on
Amazon quarterly no interest and here's
what they Market a good credit history
could help you buy a car rent an
apartment and more start building yours
by applying below goodness gracious
Predators man this is disgusting
Predators but hey the cards are pretty
John hey that should be
the that should be a segment on the
George camel show To Catch a Predator o
and you should read um the fine print
from credit card companies credit card
oh my gosh uh ads that are praying on
certain groups of people military folks
elderly folks 18-year-olds everybody
yeah hey parents do yourselves a favor
intercept this junk mail and shred it
light it on fire and then explain to
your kids why they should never sign up
for a credit card at 18 years old this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day second Corinthians
4:18 so we fix our eyes not on what is
seen but what is unseen since what is
seen is temporary but what is unseen is
eternal Al ree said you don't have to
focus on everything to be successful but
you do have to focus on something good
stuff there Addie joins us up next in
Anchorage Addie welcome to the
show hey thank you what's going
on all right so me and my husband are in
baby four five and six this is a
question that if whenever I was paying
off my $100,000 in student loan debt I
would have rolled my eyes at because
we're in a position now where we can
financially afford um to get our
vehicles fixed however um it feels like
this week has just been one thing after
another we have $60,000 in our savings
and a mortgage of 280 we have two paid
for cars and one is what I would say
like a beater we got it and we shared it
for a year it has $1,000 worth of um
things that need be fixed on it but my
husband believes that he can handle that
um and so that is our Trailblazer it's
04 and then we have a 2017 Hyundai that
we paid for in cash in 2021 it was kind
of in the um I'm sorry in 20 yeah 2021
it was kind of in the incline of like
the appreciation of um cars Ed card
value but we we paid 16,000 yes we paid
16,000 for this 2017 uh Santa Fe Hyundai
and it was Kelly Blue booking for around
21,000 so we felt like we had a good
deal we had a mechanic check it out and
it has been a good car for us for the
past two years since then we've added
two kids and this week I have been in
the car auto shop place for over six
hours with two children under two and so
I'm frustrated and we have um today I
was told
that in order to get the um Hyundai fix
the one that we have the most invested
into it's going to be
$5,700 now I understand that this is
just one person's quote however I don't
imagine that that number will fluctuate
too much going to a different auto shop
in our area and so me and my husband are
presented with the issue to be able to
decide are we going to put in $5,700 in
order to get it fixed and it's not like
a cosmetic issue it's more like an
engine issue or I hope it's not cosmetic
for that that's wild yeah yeah no I
don't care you should see our
Trailblazer and it's like we didn't even
know Alaska had radio until we got a new
car and so we we piled through we piled
through our debt and moved up here to do
that and so we paid off $100,000 um in a
couple
years so we're in a good position um
financially and we have the Savings in
order to just go out and buy you said
you had 50k in
savings we have 60k in savings and that
and of that would be our 3 to six months
um emergency fund um or expenses um and
so we um we just put like literally last
week put up the pay off the house uh
picture in order to shade off room by
room and then we get hit with us so we
just trying to decide would you um put
in the money to fix the 16 the Hyundai
which is Kelly weing around $16,000
right now is that with the that need to
be
made um it would not that would include
like if it was just fine and ready to go
so this 5700 you could sell it for
16 yes okay and if you don't you're
selling it for 10 or
less yes got it and you're wondering do
we do this or do we just upgrade the car
and sell it as is for the 10
grand right so let's say you sell it for
10 and you buy another car with 20
that's 30 you can put towards something
but they would just hurt emotionally
because either way this
sucks it's not like there's an amazing
shortcut how do we move yeah how do we
move past this we actually have money in
order to upgrade or to fix but we are
feeling like I guess the pressure of
just like okay hold on we don't want to
sink another listen there's no pressure
any pressure you feel is imaginary
anytime I get desperate or I get
frustrated I make stupid choices stupid
yes yes you just spent 6 hours in a
mechanic shop with two little kids you
should make no decisions none not even
what's for dinner for 72
hours every nerve you have it's like
getting like you just have like four
root canals just unfilled right now
right so I would rather fly to Alabama
on a plane with those two than Auto all
day long yes shots fired at the state of
Alabama so listen there there's zero
pressure that's where we're from oh
there we go listen you have $50,000 in
the
bank you have no pressure
here what you have to decide is how you
want to solve this problem but you have
the tools to solve it so any pressure
you feel I would say slow
down 100% chance get another opinion on
this that's a really high I totaled my
car totaled it and they said the repair
um was going to be about 6,000 bucks I
don't know what they're repairing on a
Hyundai for for what is that 5 thou six
for 6,000 bucks who knows maybe they got
to replace the entire engine but it's
feel I feel like you could get an entire
engine for
$6,000 right here's the other piece I
want you to think through I can't think
of a climate that would beat up a car
more than Anchorage
Alaska and I don't know you keep calling
these cars I've invested this money in
you are not you are putting money in a
depreciating asset there is no
investment Happening Here so you keep
spending money on your vehicles which is
great you have the money you'll work
hard and you're kick and butt I would
not personally um spend a whole bunch of
money on brand new cars in a climate
where half the year the roads are salted
like crazy where I'm getting rocks and
snow and they're frozen I I wouldn't I
wouldn't invest that kind of money in a
really nice
car for sure and so I think that youall
need a nice dinner and some time away
from this for just a second cuz what's
going to happen is you're going to go we
have to get a brand new $50,000 car
because remember that time we were in
the shop for 6 hours it was awful so you
need to give yourself a little bit of
space before you make a terrible
financial decision and maybe even this
you know what like I know on the Ramy
show like just make it and then move on
I can see if if let's say this you're my
wife and we're having this conversation
and we both agree let's just bite the
bullet and pay the money and fix this
car if I'm your husband I would go get
the car detail
super nice get the Shar carpet shampooed
clean it up maybe get to put a radio in
it I'm going to do something so feels a
little bit not like that old car that
just cost you an entire day of your life
and $6,000 more dollars right there's a
little that's that's a nothing it's a
token but it is like a it's an olive
branch towards hey we got bigger goals
and our bigger goal is we paid off 100
Grand and now let's buy ourselves a home
and let's just don't have one pissed off
awful kid screaming diapers everywhere
day in a mechanic shop and then spend
$30,000 on a depreciating asset that
Alaska's going to
destroy right I know that's so I don't
think we were helpful at
all take a breather and either way
you're gonna be okay y listen you have
$50,000 hear me say this any anxiety you
feel is
imaginary if you called me and said I'm
a single mom of two kids in Anchorage
Alaska and they told me I have to have
$6,000 and I have no
money then I would be scared to death
for you that's not your situation the
position where I need to change my
mindset of we are out of debt we are
free we're not like in this stress
anymore and we have the position to make
a decision rather than just what life
happen to us yes now what you're doing
is you're
transitioning you're transitioning from
this is an emergency to this is super
annoying just an inconvenience super
annoying man cuz we want to do something
else with that six grand like anything
else other than fix this car but here we
are I'll tell you one story John life
hack we were going to buy my car my wife
upgrade her old car it was going to be
like 18 grand for like a Mazda SUV this
was back in 2020 and instead we found
one that was way older but it was eight
grand and I was like how about this I'll
put carplay in it so I spent like 700
bucks and got the thing upgraded with
carplay and it felt like a brand new car
I drove deta really nice it was awesome
it fantastic so there's always but
there's always that thing in your mind
where you're like we need that new car
John it's so much more reliable it's so
much more no you got to get over it it's
mostly for ego at that point just bite
the bullet pay the money and then do one
little nice thing to make it super we
both destroy our cars yes so and I've
seen your car John you personally
destroyed it I've pushed your car down
the highway so there's that's a true
story we don't talk about that we don't
talk about Bruno or my Tesla that puts
this hour of the ramsy show in the books
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give
generously hey it's George camel if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsey Baby Steps go to Ramsey
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
started